i think we settled into
our our roles as husband and wife like
fairly quickly
and now nick jonas and priyanka chopra
are getting the hang of their newest
roles as mom and dad last week the
couple announced they welcomed a baby
and a source tells et they are both
quote so happy and settling into
parenthood nicely it's been an
incredible incredible ride quote
priyanka and nick always wanted to have
children together priyanka is very
maternal and has wanted to be a mother
for a long time they were determined to
have a baby no matter what um babies as
many as god would give us on friday the
lovebirds posted this message to
instagram writing quote we are overjoyed
to confirm that we have welcomed a baby
via surrogate this is a special thing
now et source adds quote this is
something they both really wanted so
they're thrilled and appreciative my
life is very good right now very excited
the 29 year old singer and the 39 year
old actress tied the knot back in 2018.
communication having fun with each other
i think that's the most important the
key is to be able to enjoy each other's
company and just have a great time it
doesn't feel like work
both nick and priyanka have said they
want kids but a source told et in 2019
that the couple wasn't putting any
pressure on themselves and we're just
enjoying married life
i feel a sense of self at the moment
with myself professionally where i am
the work that i'm doing the work that
i'm creating and that's my big baby you
know my career has been my greatest rock
in my whole life
a year later in 2020 things got more
serious with a source explaining that
nick and priyanka have been talking
about having children in the near future
i have a lot of faith in who my husband
is and i know i have a lot of faith in
the rock that he is for our family
plus their kid would be in good company
nick's brother kevin jonas has two
daughters valentina and elena and joe
jonas has one daughter willa
any insights into fatherhood any lessons
learned in your year plus naps are nice
[Laughter]
all around and turns out priyanka kinda
sorta hinted that they were expecting
back in november during the jonas
brothers family rose special we are the
only couple
who doesn't have kids yet
which is why i'm excited to make this
announcement
sorry babe
nick and i are expecting
yeah she flat out said it but followed
it up with this
to get drunk tonight
oh your case was really funny when i
said that
well they may not be sleeping in anymore
but one thing's for sure
nick and priyanka are one solid duo
it was kind of an instant thing knew
once we locked in together that i had a
partner for life and a teammate someone
i could walk to the good times and bad
times with and
that was that was the key i'm blushing
now
you